« Tout objectif sans plan n’est qu’un
souhait. »
a écrit Antoine de Saint-Exupéry.
La dissertation n’échappe pas à la règle.
Toute dissertation sans plan…
n’est pas une dissertation.
Oui, mais il y a beaucoup de plans possibles,
c’est-à-dire de manières différentes
de structurer l’argumentation,
alors laquelle choisir ?
Vous avez peut-être reconnu Haristote,
je suis Romain,
vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
et aujourd’hui on va parler dissertation.
Générique
Dans ma vidéo sur les 20 mots les plus importants
en dissertation
- vous pouvez la voir
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui s’affiche
en haut à droite,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description
-
dans cette vidéo,
j’avais promis de faire une vidéo sur les
plans :
la voici donc.
Je prévois de faire d’autres vidéos sur
la dissertation,
donc si ça vous intéresse
eh bien dites-moi dans les commentaires
les aspects de l’exercice
dont vous aimeriez que je parle
- par exemple l’introduction,
les transitions,
les accroches, etc.
- dites-moi vos préférences dans les commentaires.
Vous pouvez aussi m’y poser toutes vos questions,
et je répondrai à chacune d’elles sans
exception.
Et puis bien sûr,
donnez un pouce bleu
si la vidéo vous plaît ;
abonnez-vous
et activez la cloche des notifications
pour être prévenu de la publication de la
prochaine vidéo.
Ce serait bête de louper la dernière vidéo
sur la dissertation
avant un DS ou une épreuve !
Bon, allez,
trêve de précisions.
Je vais vous présenter
les sept plans de dissertation que je connais,
en allant du plus utile
au moins utile.
Pour vous épargner de prendre des notes,
j’ai fait une synthèse des sept plans
avec des schémas.
Vous pouvez la télécharger le fichier PDF
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui s’affiche
en haut à droite
soit sur celui qui est dans la description
de la vidéo,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Allez, Haristote s’ennuie déjà,
donc on passe aux plans.
On commence avec le plan dit « critique ».
Il est extrêmement simple :
il comporte deux grandes parties
dont les idées générales s’opposent,
la thèse
et l’antithèse.
La logique de ce plan,
c’est d'alterner le jugement pour combattre
le préjugé
en se plongeant successivement
dans les deux points de vue opposés
qui prévalent sur une question.
Prenons comme exemple
le sujet de philosophie du Bac S de 2017,
« Peut-on se libérer de sa culture ? ».
Les candidats pouvaient faire un plan critique
très simple :
« Si la culture détermine la manière
dont l’individu s’insère dans le monde
(I),
il semble toutefois capable de s’en émanciper
(II) ».
Le gros avantage du plan critique,
c’est qu’il est très simple ;
mais peut-être TROP simple
pour vraiment traiter le sujet,
ou tellement simple
qu’il éveille la suspicion du correcteur.
Au lycée ou pour des épreuves courtes,
ça passe,
mais je vous conseille de faire
au moins trois parties en dissertation
- comme avec le plan dialectique.
Ce plan,
vous le connaissez probablement
sous la dénomination
« thèse »
« antithèse »
« synthèse » ;
mais le mot « synthèse » me pose problème.
Si on y réfléchit bien,
ça n’a pas de sens de conclure avec une
position médiane,
qui soit une synthèse des deux premières,
parce que la vérité,
ou la sagesse,
ne se situe pas forcément au milieu.
Et puis en pratique,
c’est une consigne très vague
pour construire la troisième partie,
ce qui explique que le grand trois est souvent
plutôt raté.
Donc les trois parties du plan dialectique
sont plutôt :
thèse,
antithèse,
et dépassement.
Et en effet,
en philosophie,
la dialectique c’est le mouvement de la
pensée
qui oppose des contraires
dans le but de les dépasser.
Donc le grand trois ne doit pas
mélanger le grand un et le grand deux,
mais avancer des éléments de réponse nouveaux,
qui ont émergé
grâce à la réflexion menée dans les deux
premières parties.
Si je reprends comme exemple
le sujet de philosophie du Bac S de 2017,
« Peut-on se libérer de sa culture ? »,
on peut aussi le traiter avec un plan dialectique
comme :
« Si la culture détermine la manière dont
l’individu s’insère dans le monde (I),
il est toutefois capable de s’en émanciper
(II),
et il peut même,
en prenant conscience qu’il en est acteur,
la transformer (III). »
Le plan dialectique,
c'est de loin le plus utile et le plus flexible.
Au sens strict,
il doit forcément commencer par la thèse
et l’antithèse,
mais en pratique,
la règle c’est que les trois parties
sont structurées par des liens logiques
(opposition,
cause,
conséquence,
addition,
illustration)
- et la plupart du temps
un des deux liens est d’opposition.
Le plan dialectique est particulièrement
efficace
en philosophie et en culture générale,
mais il peut fonctionner dans toutes les disciplines.
Son inconvénient principal,
c'est la difficulté à trouver cette fameuse
troisième partie.
Je compte faire une vidéo sur les manières
de la trouver,
donc abonnez-vous
et activez la cloche des notifications
pour être prévenu de la publication de cette
vidéo.
Mais si vous voulez,
vous pouvez déjà me poser toutes vos questions
dans les commentaires.
Allez, on passe au suivant.
Le plan analytique consiste en trois parties
qui sont explicitement dirigées
vers la résolution d’un problème.
Il en existe deux,
voire trois versions.
La première c’est :
aspects (I), causes (II), conséquences (III).
La deuxième c’est :
aspects (I), causes (II), solutions (III)
- on remplace les conséquences par les solutions.
Et puis en mixant les deux,
ça en donne une troisième :
aspects (I.A.), causes (I.B.),
conséquences (II.A.), solutions (II.B.)
La logique de ce plan,
elle est inspirée de la méthode médicale
:
le diagnostic
(les aspects et les causes),
le pronostic
(les conséquences probables),
et la thérapeutique
(les remèdes).
Le médecin constate les symptômes de la
maladie ;
il en induit les causes probables ;
il fait des hypothèses concernant l’évolution
du mal ;
et enfin il prescrit des remèdes au patient.
Si j’ai à traiter un sujet d’histoire
ou d’économie assez bateau
sur la mondialisation, par exemple,
je pourrais faire le plan analytique suivant
:
Tout d’abord, Les aspects de la mondialisation
les flux accrus de marchandises, de capitaux,
et d’hommes ;
Ensuite, les causes de la mondialisation :
le progrès technique, les réglementations,
etc. ;
Et enfin, les effets de la mondialisation
:
la croissance économique,
les inégalités,
l'interpénétration des cultures,
la résurgence des nationalismes, etc.
Le plan analytique est assez pratique
parce qu’il est prêt à l’emploi
et transparent pour le correcteur.
Après,
tous les sujets ne s’y prêtent pas,
et puis il est assez mécanique,
pas trop littéraire
- c’est pour ça qu’il est surtout utile
pour les épreuves courtes,
comme les interrogations orales.
Le plan thématique comporte généralement
trois parties,
chacune assignée,
comme le nom l’indique,
à un thème particulier.
Alors, je reprends l’exemple d’un sujet
sur la mondialisation.
On peut faire un plan thématique
à partir de la définition de la mondialisation
comme augmentation des flux de marchandises,
de capitaux,
et de personnes.
Ça donne :
En grand un, la mondialisation de l’économie
productive ;
en grand deux, la mondialisation financière
;
et en grand trois, la mondialisation culturelle.
Le premier thème,
c’est l’augmentation des flux de marchandises
;
le deuxième
l’augmentation des flux de capitaux ;
et le troisième
l’augmentation des flux de personnes.
Avec un plan thématique,
c’est plus facile de sélectionner
les arguments et les références,
mais ce plan a plusieurs défauts :
peu de sujets s’y prêtent ;
les thèmes à retenir ne sont pas forcément
évidents ;
certains sont plus faciles à développer
que d’autres ;
et enfin,
il est plus difficile de justifier
l’ordre des grandes parties.
C’est pour ça que je ne suis pas fan du
plan thématique.
Ce plan,
c’est moi qui l’ai entre guillemets inventé,
et qui ai choisi le nom.
Je n’ai pas eu à chercher bien loin,
parce qu’il combine les deux plans précédents
:
chaque grande partie cible un thème précis
- en cela le plan est thématique -
mais chaque partie correspond en même temps
à une étape de la résolution d’un problème
- en cela, la plan est aussi analytique.
J’ai progressivement élaboré ce plan par
la pratique,
à force d’essais et d'erreurs,
lors de mes colles de langues en prépa HEC.
Étant donné l’actualité et la dimension
économique
de la grande majorité des sujets que j’avais
à commenter,
je suis arrivé à la structure suivante :
en première partie,
les symptômes sociaux du problème ;
en deuxième partie,
ses racines économiques ;
et en troisième partie,
les solutions politiques envisageables.
Par exemple,
un sujet sur la hausse du prix du pétrole
pourrait être traité avec le plan suivant
:
d’abord, les conséquences sociales du phénomène
;
ensuite, ses causes économiques ;
et enfin, les mesures politiques susceptibles
de le contenir.
Il n’y a pas grand-chose à modifier en
fait.
Alors,
la logique intellectuelle de ce plan
elle est un peu marxiste,
dans la mesure où on part du principe
que les causes des événements
sont de nature économique.
Ça,
ça lui fait un défaut évident,
qui est que la grille de lecture marxiste
peut paraître réductrice.
Autre défaut :
il convient surtout pour des sujets d’histoire,
d’économie, ou d’actualité.
Mais bon,
je l’aime bien quand même mon plan thématico-analytique,
parce qu’il est bien commode pour les épreuves
où on n’a pas le temps d’analyser le
sujet en profondeur.
Il est vraiment prêt à l’emploi,
et il combine les trois dimensions fondamentales
de l’actualité
(social, économique, politique)
telle que la présentent les grands médias.
Là, pas de mystère :
le plan chronologique comporte en général
trois parties,
qui relatent des périodes historiques successives.
A priori,
il ne peut servir que
dans les matières qui ont une dimension historique.
Je prends en exemple le sujet d’histoire
économique
tombé au concours d’entrée d'HEC en 2017,
« L’entreprise peut-elle se passer de l’entrepreneur
? ».
Moi j’aurais fait le plan suivant :
« Si l’entreprise semblait reposer sur
l’entrepreneur
lors des premières révolutions industrielles
(I),
elle a pu ensuite davantage s’en passer,
en se bureaucratisant, au profit des managers
(II),
jusqu’à ce qu’il reprenne un rôle de
premier plan
à l’occasion de la troisième révolution
industrielle (III). »
Vous pouvez remarquer
que ce plan est à la fois chronologique
ET dialectique,
car les trois parties sont articulées
par des liens logiques d’opposition.
Les avantages du plan chronologique
sa simplicité,
sa transparence pour le correcteur,
et puis le fait qu’il facilite la mobilisation
des connaissances
dans le développement de la dissertation.
Après, il convient à peu de sujets ;
le découpage des périodes peut ne pas aller
de soi ;
et puis ce plan pousse au recrachage du cours,
- alors que l’enjeu de la dissertation
c’est quand même de réfléchir.
Alors,
je n’ai pas évoqué le fameux « plan Sciences-Po
»
parce qu’en fait il ne correspond à aucune
structure précise
(on sait juste qu’il faut faire quatre parties).
En revanche,
quand j’ai préparé le concours de l’ENA,
je me suis familiarisé avec un type de plan
assez particulier
que j’appelle du coup « plan ENA »
(faute de mieux).
Il s’agit d’un plan en quatre parties
:
en un A, le rappel des faits essentiels ;
en un B, la mise en balance des théories
pertinentes ;
en deux A, le bilan des solutions mises en
œuvre ;
et enfin en deux B,
les pistes de solutions futures.
Voici par exemple le plan que j’avais fait
en prep’ENA
pour le sujet d’économie « Le protectionnisme
est-il voué à disparaître ? » :
Ma première partie, c’était
Les mesures protectionnistes caractérisent
encore le commerce international
à l'heure de la mondialisation ;
La deuxième,
Le protectionnisme peut être légitime
dans certaines circonstances transitoires
;
En deux A,
Le libre-échange a progressé de manière
discontinue,
avec des reflux de protectionnisme ;
Et enfin en quatrième partie,
les solutions futures :
Préférable au protectionnisme,
le libre-échange peut encore progresser
grâce au développement des négociations
commerciales.
Ce plan « ENA » a deux avantages principaux
:
d’abord il est prêt à l’emploi
- même s’il y a un gros enjeu de formulation
-
et puis il combine efficacement différents
niveaux de connaissance
- les faits, les statistiques,
les théories, et les hypothèses.
Après,
il est moins fluide que le plan dialectique
;
il demande une grande culture générale ;
et il est prescriptif,
il est porté sur l’action,
de telle sorte qu’il est principalement
utile
dans des matières comme l’économie,
ou la science politique
- des matières qui sont au concours de l’ENA.
Mais bon,
je trouve la structure de ce plan quand même
efficace,
et puis il ne faut pas hésiter à la customiser
en fonction du sujet du jour si nécessaire.
Parce que ça n’est pas la nature du plan
qui importe
- ce n’est pas parce que c’est un « plan
ENA »
qu’il est forcément génial -
non, ce qui compte,
c’est la commodité du plan pour résoudre
le problème intellectuel de la dissertation.
Ça y est,
on a donc vu les sept plans de dissertation
!
Vous pouvez télécharger la synthèse des
sept plans en PDF
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui s’affiche
en haut à droite
soit sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Alors,
ça peut être bien de connaître les sept,
mais autant en maîtriser parfaitement un
ou deux,
plutôt que d’hésiter entre les sept
et de n’en maîtriser véritablement aucun.
Pour ma part,
je ne fais presque plus que des plans dialectiques,
parce que c’est vraiment un plan « tout
terrain »,
adaptable à tous les sujets
et toutes les disciplines.
La seule limite,
c’est qu’il faut un peu de pratique
pour trouver des troisièmes parties satisfaisantes.
Et puis il faut aussi de la pratique
pour formuler efficacement le plan.
Bref,
c’est toujours pareil :
la réussite récompense l’effort.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la vidéo
suivante.
Posez-moi toutes vos questions en commentaire
et je répondrai à chacune d’entre elles.
Encore une fois,
vous pouvez télécharger la synthèse des
sept plans en PDF
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui s’affiche
en haut à droite
soit sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Voici connaissez Haristote,
je suis Romain,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
N’oubliez pas que
vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête
pour progresser en dissertation.